[Music]
in control that crap news crab rollin
crap okay front submitted by what Putin
Goodman II know what your wife's
language design animal I'll never know
I'll never know you should say that to
her dad the most narrow with hanging
them all is it bad word yeah [ __ ]
Mazda means yeah [ __ ] your mom wait what
it means [ __ ] your mom yeah yeah damn
dude that's a pretty brutal a most
narrow but I knew things the FDA is
urging manufacturers of anti diarrhea
medicine to sell in smaller quantities
so people can't use it to get high what
the [ __ ] they get high off that [ __ ] and
an area is that gonna be like in rap
songs now oh yeah just some [ __ ]
pepto get some [ __ ] pepped alright to
make you put yeah imodium podium all you
could get high up
imodium a baby no apparently ammonia was
part of the opioid family yeah you
[ __ ] up on the motor over that [ __ ]
Walter why someone would have told me
when I was doing but yeah was just kind
of water in that [ __ ] yeah drink like
have a [ __ ] bottle I should [ __ ] me
up like a [ __ ] I did it like
it's wrong I did it for drug use cuz my
friend told me to do it Oh what did it
we bought and it had to have like a
certain chemical in there he's a nerd so
he knew and we drank half the bottle and
I felt like I was on E I do not
recommend this because you should never
ever why did you say
take that [ __ ] well I was I was a [ __ ]
dumbass 13 year old editor's you guys
understand put a big bleep over
everything he just says so soon he
starts complete until I was that was
that what is that yeah dude you're
advising some really [ __ ] up [ __ ] just
putting a disclaimer
you should never I made a mistake you
made some very enticing it doesn't make
you look bad but it gives them ideas I
don't mean [ __ ] do it
no bleep it believe it bleep you think
the brand a specific brand no we need to
believe that [ __ ] out cuz you're getting
to this because if I can channel my
stupid ass 13 year old self I would not
listen to any warning all I heard was it
was fun as [ __ ] yep yep so sorry kids
not today we love you too much eat
play-doh if you want to get [ __ ] up
it's nasty it's so salty nice good
because it's salty but it's nasty good
Leto know that this will lead to much of
it like two tubs of it well you ate
play-doh before you cut it into shapes
kids you [ __ ] up the science show
saltiness is what it tastes like you you
[ __ ] got somebody sweat after working
on you wring that [ __ ] [ __ ] out and
soaked it up in some dough you know
what's really popular that's slime [ __ ]
that kids are doing the slime stuff I
was now it's late
oh just hypothesis you [ __ ] up seems
to be doing oh really
you can you di-in't iPod there's
anything like a few tenants detergent
but you can have like one none if you
like the blue side yeah you just bring
yourself because that's a little kick
boy I like to say I probably would be a
lot smarter if I didn't do all those
stupid things see I'm glad you've
discovered that sometimes my brain skips
a heartbeat though is that dude that
Drake bleach that tried to kill himself
but it didn't work out the way he wanted
to and he survived and so they had to
attach his esophagus to like the his
smaller intestine and so he
I guess his stomach is completely gone
so when he eats whatever you eat sir
processes or some [ __ ] or only a small
part of the stomach is there so he has
[ __ ] every two hours
Wow if his life was about enough well on
the brighter side you'll really really
do well at buffets that's true he'll
kill he'll kill food challenge us and
kill it I just pictured the guy with no
stomach in this just chest and legs
right yeah what that like the pizza
challenge all that [ __ ] they're like hey
man yeah get the [ __ ] out of here dude
you're the customer
it's not fair to question the game you
gotta get out of here yeah so apparently
a lot of people consume imodium as a way
to get high or if they're trying to like
kick another opioid like heroin or
something then the but doesn't it
prevent you from [ __ ] yeah that's a
concrete I don't know yeah I don't know
if I want to be constipated for a few
days be constipated for three four days
at a time yeah the way you say it was
such a walk way of Santa like you're
wearing a bucket reverse hair net and
you're like in a classroom we're like yo
T that's what I used to do teach like
will you save me like that kind of I
didn't know that you had to poop every
day saw was about 14 years old this is
my high school days this is what not to
do
I would eat like one meal a day or so
and it was flamin hot cheetos in a hot
pocket party flamin hot cheetos in cup
of noodles i would sprinkle the flamin
cheetos and on top that was my that was
my milk my parents fed me okay but I
purposely did not eat so I could get
higher so when I go to the rave at night
I could be like oh my god it's cheaper
to just buy a one pill
but okay this is what happened okay but
I wouldn't poop that much and I think
it's because of like anxiety and bad
food so I lack of food lack of food
right my body's probably absorbing every
little nutria doing this [ __ ] the rain
like that's a lot of yes problem you
know what's so funny yeah and his
starting bra oh my god I've destroyed my
gut you're the most heavily planned
person to ruin your own life like you
thought you'd like you plan to make it
it's like a combination of like
stupidity and also being really poor
spreadsheets to take MDM oh by the way I
went to church and I got just as [ __ ]
up and a lot of fun that's one thank you
there you go Church to it and dated like
me there I'll give her a high around you
said no because man my friends was that
you doing this that's my rave yeah
that's my raver guy they would get the
UH they would you know the the Bible
since it's like really thin pages they
would use that as joint roller and then
go back I wasn't cool with no yeah I
wasn't cool with that last one I took a
hit but I wasn't cool I didn't realize I
was not a part of this oh there's a
there's a lot of pages in the Bible that
have nothing to do with the scripture it
wasn't the back pages the editor pane oh
there he go yeah
probably yeah you know what he needs
those pages it has like the old map of
Macedonia and also the [ __ ] glossary
yeah you don't need that [ __ ] sometimes
there's just pages till it matches cuz
it's two-sided so that the [ __ ] fold
the paper right beside with the eyes
being not oh my god you know [ __ ]
ISBN number did you sell books what are
you talking about who knows about an
ISBN numbers when you go to the library
that's how you search for books how many
books you read huh they teach you this
when you go to the library and you get a
library card you see it you search from
the I she's trying to make fun of you on
common knowledge yeah and then everyone
just came down I was surprised that I've
ever I've never how many times have you
used a word [ __ ] is be and outside of
the library like I'm really angered
right now and you turned this fun moment
into something very sad angry I was so
surprised like it was like oh you know
what I mean like it's like I just saw a
unicorn that's all do you remember go in
the library and then yet to like search
which ones it was in that category and
you find the book and you pull that
thing and you get that card and you go
find it yeah that's the I it's been
there oh really
I'm so stupid what do you just say that
I'm stupid why are you all night I want
you to keep on talking please keep going
I thought that was awesome well I was
happy to hear Iseman it made me happy
becomes words love continue the FDA is
asking manufacturers back to this whole
imodium thing they're asking
manufacturers to package their
medications in smaller quantities
because there are some generic versions
that are sold in boxes of up to 200
tablets
that's pretty innocent are you really
only to use a modem like once or twice
yeah it's like Costco size they look
like in case you guys are wondering so
that's what you want to buy yeah that's
what you want to buy they always ruin
the fun man I gotta say well sometimes
people get some and stomachaches they
have to rely on that for like a lifetime
but it's not good to take a Bodi on my
head though
yeah but it's like for example I get
sicker than ever now because I can't
take no tsuita fit anymore because it
gets a bunch of meth people make soup
make meth out of sudafed errs oh really
yeah so I like your idea or some [ __ ] no
I know but it's it's like behind the
glass thing I got a lot yeah it's hard
to get any weight the Lyra tube while
you get it like nah we want you really
say panel so have to really just act it
up you know I don't know why I'm like
you've clearly only make it man i
stacked the deck against myself I don't
know why I do I don't want to try making
this at least once I don't love it you
want to make it destroy because I want
to sell it or you I just want to try
making it just because I saw you know
Breaking Bad yeah breaking that made it
sexy
exactly and fun looking exactly it looks
like one of those crystal projects that
you get when you buy and then like you
you you like put what I now want to be
you know make that good [ __ ] where you
know methods are like that's the good
[ __ ] and can't have it I just made it it
looks like MSG what if you end up making
some like really good [ __ ] would you be
done and just continue how much how much
am I going to make off of it though see
this is the things I don't know I don't
know the market price that's so amore I
like matching his hypothetical like okay
Ford if you came he became a drug
kingpin you know what stress that would
bring
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]